Hello,
hello, hello!
Hello, hello!
Hello!
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello, hello.
Howdy, howdy, howdy.
Each time I play this game, I get bored of bored.
Like, uh, like, I like, uh, wait, like, not traumatized.
It's like, First I go dark mode and now I have an eye patch.
The toils of war taking its toll zombie.
Sorry, my brain is not braining today.
Yeah, we're corrupted.
More and more punished.
Yes, welcome back to To Control.
Fair warning.
My coordination today is quite...
of Minto with two eyepatches for the finale of course Tunar
welcome back Emo minky yes, so Emo is so sad Matara and I we
went out to we went out to a lunch and We were like trying
to eat And like I was dropping all my my my silverware and
Matara was flinging food We were just, we were like, oh my
gosh, what's wrong with us?
One second.
Let me actually...
I
was trying to...
Oh!
I was trying to move my mic a little bit, but I muted so
that it wasn't like...
In her ear.
Oh, God.
Little sleep deprivation butterfingers.
Oh, I've been sleeping so good.
Um...
Johnny he's been very um oh he's going through some mood
swings I believe I mean I've only had him for like a week
ish so he's still getting used to the place but um he like
runs all over me at night and now he's gotten into this like
he just doesn't stop meowing unless he's asleep what's wrong
with you yeah It's, uh, oh, it's been, it's been something.
His rebellious phase already.
It seems like it, right?
Um, yeah, I'm like, there's a couple things because I'm
noticing, I'm noticing, well, the most frustrating thing,
uh, is that he's been biting everything.
Um, it's because he doesn't have nanomachines.
Exactly.
He's been biting everything.
I noticed my my very rare metal gear Stan D has now cat
teeth marks on and I had my from Minto with love from
the the
the foam like the the foam boards that were with the standy
or not sorry with the uh with the flower stand um he was
biting those earlier so i've never had a cat that's been
this bad uh so it's a little adjustment for me too and i've
noticed that on some of his toys uh that he likes to bite
particularly he uh there's like bloodstains right so I think
he's having I've already noticed his teeth are quite mangled
so I think he actually has I have to take him to the vet and
I think he has quite issues with his teeth and I think that
makes him want to bite and want to is he teething he better
not be he's a couple years old I got a cat a couple years
old because I did not want a kitten and I here dealing with
a kitten.
I had to get shelves with doors to protect my stuff from
Haru-chan.
Oh, no.
I couldn't get a ticket for your Vexpo meet and greet this
weekend, so take this instead.
Koishi, thank you!
Hopefully I'll see you in some capacity if I see you at the
maid cafe.
Times are not confirmed, but I should be at the maid cafe on
some sort of iPad at some point in time.
But yeah, sorry if I'm a little grumpy.
Sorry if I'm a Sorry if I'm a little grumpy, sorry if I'm a
little low energy.
But I don't want to keep talking about it, because...
I've already... I don't know.
My Hikaria knows how many plushies have arrived, but it
seems like they might get a spooky friend at some point.
They might!
We're just hoping things go well with Johnny.
recently adopted cats.
Wishing the best.
Also, congrats on the Dragon's Dogma 2 official pawn collab.
I know.
That's kind of crazy.
It's kind of funny.
I was like, I was like.
They asked if I wanted to do it.
And I was like, well, I've never played Dragon's Dogma.
But I think if anybody does play, it might be kind of fun if
you have.
If you have a Minto running around with you.
So.
Um.
Yeah, I thought it was a little funny, so, uh, yeah.
Not to re-download the game just for Vinto.
I thought it was so interesting, too, because, like, it's a
bit of an older game, so I was like, huh.
Well, yeah, so, um...
We'll, uh...
We'll play Control today.
I don't... I don't know.
go for as long as i feel like i mentally can again
unfortunately these games are always so like how do you say
so your brain is everywhere and my brain is already
everywhere so wanted to say congrats on the dragon dog but
two crossover that was a big surprise wondering wondering
they had you record wolves hunt in packs or ought of use i
did not record anything actually um we literally just made
the pawn and that's it giving good and vibe energies to my
stinky ghost thank you thank you thank you thank you thank
you big fan of capcom games it was pretty fun surprise it
was it was funny to see see me in there i didn't expect them
to announce it like that so i was like wow uh needo needo
very needo but um yeah i just wanted uh you know obviously i
like control but i do want to i want to see what's going on
i want to get all of our questions answered hopefully and um
and and uh uh get through the game so we can start on other
things as well i mean i like your outfit thank you thank you
saw your plushie announced mount good smile yeah it's so
cool i can't believe it it's very it's um For people that
are wondering, it's not a Fumo style.
It's a different plushy style.
So if you were like, well, I got Fuminto.
It's also, I think, much smaller than Fuminto.
It was wonderful meeting you in Moshe last week.
Back time.
Thanks for being so sweet.
To a nervous, I boo.
Also, congrats on the good smile, plushy, my Vito collection
grows.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It has, actually, they've been really awesome.
to uh uh to work with they they sent me pictures of the
prototype actually last time i was in japan they even
offered to give me a tour of the of the studio there just
unfortunately wasn't enough time but um is it small enough
to take to a wrestling show i believe it's similar size to
to to tiny minky plushie so maybe i think it's similar size
actually um but they but they they we've been working on
this for a while of course as most things are right um and
uh they sent me photos and then then i got word from like
the japanese team they were like actually we're gonna rework
some of this because because we want to make it cuter And I
was like, wow, it was already so cute.
And so they were like, yeah, we're going to edit a few
things to, like, even make it better.
And I was like, wow.
And then the team, they were so nice.
Like, there's a little special surprise to it that Good
Smile themselves, the team they suggested.
And I was like, I was like, wait, this is so fun.
So, yeah, when I can show you guys, I'll show you.
You can make a bit cuter.
I'll take 50.
Godfoul, thank you so much for 29 months.
So, yeah, I'm excited to show you guys eventually.
Just spent 10 minutes in control running around, trying to
find the entrance to maintenance.
Then I died in the game, literally pointed me at the
elevator.
You'll never hear VTuber lost from me.
This game, I would be so lost.
I would be so lost if not for you.
you guys helping also blue archive sponsor stream tomorrow
by oh she keeps winning yeah i'm very i'm i'm quite nervous
about it well usually i like i don't know like i guess with
certain things i don't know like i'm not super sweaty about
games in general you know and so i know some people can be
so sweaty about like games but for me i just like you know i
just kind of enjoy playing and so i'm like, you know, I
never really show off my Blue Archive stuff because I'm, I
don't know.
I don't know.
I'm just, I get, I'm just, I'm just, I'm just a baby.
Yeah, I'm just a vibing baby.
I'm just, I'm all vibes.
I saw Capcom including Dragon Dog Batu.
I'm, well, my pawn is there.
Yeah.
So, I don't know.
I just kind of like, I'm like, I'm just, I'm just here for
the girls.
But I'm excited for that too.
Yes, yes, yes.
And it's my first solo Blue Archive stream.
So, yeah.
Expecting a lot of YouTuber, have you not fully optimized
your gotcha comments?
I don't know.
It's like, you know, I've always...
It's, you know, there's always going to be someone who...
i mean they tweeted about me so i'm scared like they tweeted
about me i'm always you know what i'm someone who's just
like oh she she her her uh relationship with koharu is not
max how dare i don't know i'm just i'm just a baby but um i
think most sensei's are chill yeah i think so too no rc this
time no rc this time just just just just me just me so we'll
uh we'll be going a little over there i do have a schedule
so oh yeah oh as long as you enjoy it no big deal i don't
know i get nervous i get anxious about things i'm just a
ball of anxious and my brain is not so my brain today i
could finally eat my ocean no no do you think you'll pull
mootski i really want She's so cute.
Dress Mutsuki.
But...
Um, I mean, that's part of the...
Well, we're gonna be pulling for her and Haruka, so...
And it hints as to when the Good Smile plush will be
available.
I can't say so much, but...
Uh...
More info soon.
Asterisk.
Might be thinking Superhead, but have you ever done?
do a Nendo in the future, it has the spot reserved right
next to all the MGS Nendo's on display.
If I do a, if I if I get a Nendo in the future, it'd be
pretty cool.
We'll see, though.
We'll see how the plushie does.
um and I don't know.
We'll see.
I guess we'll see.
Nothing like that is in the works.
at the moment so um congrats busy busy ghosty vibrito thank
you so much oh my gosh buddies thank you so much for the 50
guilt and thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you
but yeah you're hoping any minto figure oh i hope so i hope
so maybe something right But yeah, shall we get started with
control.
Sorry, I am like, so my brain...
Sorry, I keep complaining.
Or not complaining, but like, you know.
Ah!
I'll do my bus today.
Could a poor sickly Ibu be so forward as to bother you for a
feel-better meme?
No!
better be feel better more kojima tapes today kojima coming
on this well we can try to get the other tape isn't there
two new to the minto lore saw your first time meeting henya
was adorable is there any other vtubers you acted that way
with welcome welcome to minto lore i don't know i'm also i'm
just pretty shy in general so but i had no you know i'm a
big fan of henya and you know have been for a while so I'm
so excited for Good Smile March on the Dragon's Dogma 2
You're a Vinto I'm in It's so strange People are seeing me
on Capcom stream But I love Capcom They You know I've only I
haven't received many PR packages In my afterlife In fact
I've received to and both were from Capcom so I'm very I'm
very very you know I'm like thanks Capcom for thinking of me
thanks Capcom for thinking of me very cool and popular
retuber no neither of those but Capcom loves vtuber like
maybe maybe so i have i think it's just you know really nice
of them to include me um when when i'm just i'm just little
old me so oh i'm just little old me you know yes yes let's
continue we were just about to head into the mines but
before i do that i do want to
uh we stopped here right wow wow i think he yeah janitor's
office is right here i think we're gonna get ambushed in
here probably though so uh let me remember let me look at
the controlling um i'm pretty sure i remember though pretty
sure i remember if yeah yeah shield shield i don't use most
so much though um hey so welcome back thanks me and everyone
of course we'll I can't believe your birthday is gonna be
the day Ace Combat release.
No, my birthday is on the first.
Ace Combat is on the second.
No, don't be neglecting my birthday.
It's a different day.
It's been a great playthrough.
Thanks for playing this.
Thanks for watching.
I really appreciate it.
Controls, that's the name of the game.
You know, I had like such a dumb moment earlier.
Wow.
team there looks awesome right coming out of those vents wow
i didn't notice before it's a this is a really good looking
game i'll give it that even if sometimes the people look a
little uncanny but that's just sometimes these types of
games um uh i had a silly moment earlier where i was like
the fbc the federal bureau of control oh control i was like
wait a second Wait a second!
I was like, oh no.
Why am I so stupid?
Oh, wait.
What is that?
Oh, control is evade.
Okay, okay, okay.
Roll credits.
Wrap it up, boys.
We did it.
I was like, wait, how did I...
How did I not...
Okay, hold on.
This was where the Black Rock Quarry was, though.
Yeah, we went up this staircase.
Whoa, why was that red and then just turned green?
That's kind of scary.
Who unlocked the door?
Who unlocked that?
That's kind of scary.
Your birthday's on the 3rd of October.
Oh my gosh, we're almost winning!
Alright, let's go get ambushed in here.
I just took that guy's body.
Whoa!
So much mold!
I wish to... to eat it.
Okay, a tea was over that one.
Oh, we got some materials.
Mold.
I wish to eat the mold.
Yeah, janitor's office.
We went in there before.
He's over here.
Consume the mold.
Hi!
Makes good coffee.
Let me know how the audio is, by the way.
Oh, let's see what we got here.
What a mess.
Clear the clog.
Oh, what's back?
It's like the clog from before, no?
Game's a bit quiet.
Okay.
The game, the game is...
Here, actually.
Sometimes I hear it louder than you guys, so of course,
please let me know.
But yeah, the poop monster is back.
Yeah, who we love to see it.
Poop monster.
Look at it.
Came from over here.
And, uh, yeah, we love to see it.
You don't?
Well, hold on, let's see where that's at.
If I...
Then...
It's...
Oh, I'm blocking it with my head, but it's right next to the
coolant pumps at the bottom.
Hey, boss, I've had a pretty crummy day, too.
It's okay to feel down, low energy, but we can all be a
little grumps doing our best together.
Yeah, we're a little grumps doing our best together.
Actually, on Steam Page, for me, it says Ace Combat, it's
going to be released October 1st.
Even my pre-order says that too, so it still counts.
Okay, okay.
We're grumps.
Wait, what's up?
What's up?
Game grumps.
I'm grump.
I'm not so grump.
Wait, I'm grump.
I'm even more grump.
We are the game grumps.
Mint's head acts as coolant pumps.
Yeah, I'm the coolant.
It's right next to them.
that's kind of cool oh where is that it's actually an area
that I have not here I'll show you oh lame never mind I was
gonna show you that it's like an area we haven't been to yet
before so that's okay wait why is it blocked wait why is it
locked oh it's unlocked one scary everybody be yapping oh oh
Okay, so we went over here and then in here, I believe, was
the way to the...
Yes, the quarry.
Alright, here we go.
I'm yearning.
I'm yearning for...
for love and for the mines.
I'm yearning for a good night's rest.
Oh, wait, there's an elevator here.
Okay.
Beep beep.
I could turn up just...
Let me know if it gets too loud, for real.
I mean, I know you guys will.
Awkward.
There's a couple guys there.
There's a save point.
I could have gone here instead.
We do be yearning.
We do a little yearning here.
Claim.
Oh.
Do they notice?
Will they notice?
They're so stupid.
Where's the rest of them?
Wait, where'd they go?
Whoa, whoa, where'd they go?
Whoa, what?
Whoa, what do you have?
What do you have?
Whoa!
They took out a big chunk of me!
What just happened?
Oh, my health!
Was that the sniper?
Yowch!
Holy cow!
Um...
I think I still got him, though.
Oh, more guys just spawned.
Oh, it's one of these bozos.
Oh, my health, though.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I feel like I want to...
Well, let's go grab the health here.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
I am a bit of a gamer sometimes.
When I choose to be.
I...
Oh, boy.
Oh, my god.
Counter-sniper.
I thought those guys were...
My weapons mods are full!
I think I have to go do these at the control point, you
know?
Incredible shot.
Thank you very much.
I thought those guys avoided my...
Maybe it was just that one dude, huh?
Constructs?
No.
You don't have to.
Just kidding them.
Whoops.
Load out.
Oh, here, here, here.
My personal mods.
Oh, wait, but how do I...
Sorry.
Oh, the deconstruct.
There we go.
Okay, let's just deconstruct some of these.
Wait, this one is clearly... Okay, then it must be weapons
mods, right?
It was weapons mods that were...
Yeah, here we go.
Let's just deconstruct all of these bad boys.
All the level ones.
Because we have so many of them.
Nice.
We got plus 800.
Okay, we can deconstruct anywhere.
Cool, cool, cool.
Okay.
Oh, there's a bot!
Sorry, let me grab him.
Get off my channel, you stinky.
Well, well.
This is different than what...
Oh, the quarry is over there, maybe?
This is different than what I expected to see.
Energy renewal.
Under here?
It was weapons, right?
Energy.
Oh!
Energy gains from headshot.
Ah, is that one, okay.
Okay, find the Black Rock quarry.
Black Rock quarry.
This is not the quarry.
No, we're not.
There.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, see it pays.
What is this?
What the hell?
NSC internal movement detected.
This is what we're seeing in there?
That's horrifying.
I don't like that at all.
Dynamic energy extraction and conversion.
Redacted sarcophagus container.
NSC.
The NSC was designed by order of deputy chief trench shortly
before he became director just some orange juice cloud the
container provides a safe method of extraction of redacted
is redacted this excess energy output while acting as a
humane way to house him him the coolant pumps keep the
container and it's redacted from overheating while the
energy is siphoned the energy is then conducted to the
converters where it is rendered into a redacted through the
use of turbine generators.
The electricity produced powers the entire bureau making is
completely self-sufficient and effectively invisible to the
New York City grid.
After NSC 01's disappearance by some unknown manifestation
of redacted diseases power, the occupant was restrained and
a second model was built.
NSC 02 possesses built-in spatial anchors that are designed
to prevent any translocative effect from being used.
its occupant i um i i forgot to say too uh that um that uh
there were some people that were like i'm kind of confused
on what the plot is going on here in the story uh basically
for my understanding it's uh there's i mean there's so many
like extra things like extra researches and and stuff sorry
I'm leaving don't milk did I miss summarize the entire game
vtuber oh I was just about to do that kind of um the plot is
yes hiss bad mint good pretty much that right it's like
that's me I'm that person sorry no don't be sorry don't be
sorry because it is quite confusing especially when they
like redact so many things and it's so like it's kind of
hard to keep track of what's going on.
Basically, we as a kid, our brother got taken by this
agency, the FBC, and we are now the director of the FBC
because we have some sort of special trait in us that
designated us to be the director after the last guy died.
And we're searching for answers on where they took our
brother we're searching for what the hiss are how it
happened we there's still a lot that has not been answered
so um we're still trying to figure out a bunch of this stuff
jesse is looking for her brother hilarity ensues it's
absolutely hilarious yeah hiss is bad entity that has
infiltrated the facility yeah yeah yeah it's meant to be
kind of confusing until things are revealed later on yeah
i'm excited for like all the answers seems like maybe dr
darling has some sort of either connection or he knew it was
coming or something something and so we can't find our
brother because we're trying to take care of the hiss first
so yes so what is the nsc what does that stand for it didn't
say
over here or do I have to go around this way?
Come on, come on.
It's just the power generator.
Got it.
So, this thing here?
Oh, it says it above the monitors.
Oh, let's go check it out.
Thank you.
Northmore sarcophagus container.
Oh, what is...
Ew, it's leaking out.
Freaky.
If you try replaying Trench's dead hotline on the previous
director, it gives an entirely new context.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to press that one.
Wait, Northmore.
Is this the, is that the previous director?
Let me, let me double, let me see.
I think we watched, listened to this one, but now I think I
have more context.
So let's watch again.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yes, yes, I remember this one.
I never wanted power.
I purposefully avoided it.
Didn't trust it.
The director is literally...
North Moore was all about power.
A man like an explosion hungry for authority.
For order.
For more.
Until it was too much.
I had to find a solution.
Sorry, he's so quiet.
Contain the situation.
Oh.
Northmore never liked me.
But he went along with it.
To his credit.
He didn't really have a choice.
Oh.
I suppose at the end of the day, a director's most basic
duty is to keep the lights on.
Quite literally.
Oh!
Here's to you, Northmore.
That's what he means!
There were no prime candidates waiting on the wings.
But I was there.
Hadn't been.
the whole time keeping my head down working my ass off i had
nothing to lose i picked up the gun almost on a dare
whoa okay so thanks thanks northmore sounds very much like
max pain's vda pretty sure it is no
Or so I've been told.
I would like to play Max Payne eventually.
Hold on.
What's over this way?
Nothing.
Okay.
Nothing here.
Remakes are coming?
Are you just saying that?
Or...
Alright.
Is this finally the quarry?
Sorry if it gets loud.
I'm still trying to adjust the audio in this game.
It's either so quiet or...
Oh, there's a shelter.
We're so loud.
Okay, first floor to the quarry.
They're remaking one or two.
One end two.
What?
Then maybe the perfect time to play it once it gets a
remake.
Hopefully the remakes are good, right?
You know, we have been to quite a handful of these shelters.
And we say that we need more of those things for the chest,
like the HRCs or whatever, to stop people from becoming more
his.
But I've been to a handful of these shelters, and there's
HRAs.
HRAs, yeah, yeah, yeah, thank you.
There's nobody in them.
So it's kind of like...
What was that?
Can I, like, drop down here?
It's kind of terrifying.
Anyway, let's go.
Oh!
Gotta get down the old-fashioned way.
Oh, then we actually do have to do this.
Okay, just kidding.
Maybe the other way is better.
maybe they're both the same oh oh it's one of these things
ew I hate you
actually does it float we all float here or is it oh oh you
can be my bud become my oh um become become yes become my
buddy Whoa, lo, lo, there we go.
But once he's dead, is he going to explode?
I guess they do.
He's just...
I want to get a good look at him.
Come here, come here.
Oh.
Ew, ew.
Ew.
Ew!
I'm not a fan.
Yuck.
Wait, how do I get down?
Oh, here.
Oh, this is scary.
Okay, I could do without you screeching in my ear every two
seconds.
That answered my question.
Did he break the lamp?
He broke the light.
that's so funny I hear another I hear like some breathing
somebody is breathing way too loud down there for my liking
but where oh gosh it's really red down there huh okay who's
breathing huh who's Who's breathing down here?
What is that noise?
Oh, it's another one.
It's the minke.
It's me!
Sorry, I was nervous.
Matara at you.
I know!
Why was she saying that?
I was breathing loud.
Except that I wasn't even breathing.
I don't breathe, you guys.
I'm dead.
She obviously was mistaken.
Oh, we good?
We good?
Oh my gosh.
My big old...
My big heart left a...
Left quite a dent in there, huh?
Oh my gosh, it's so dark down there.
Why are there...
There's more dents.
And blood?
Okay.
Oh, it's scary.
Can you...
Can you impersonate breathing?
Like that?
What is all that going on down there?
There's so much talking.
Oh, there's a control point, though.
How do I get down from here is my question.
Maybe onto there?
Ouch.
Not as scary as I thought it would be.
Just a little red.
Cleanse!
Have you guys ever been
into like a quarry.
They're quite cool to see, I think.
Is it still broken?
Oh, oh, oh, no, no, wait, oh.
I went to a salt mine in Colombia.
That was cool.
Whoa, that sounds pretty cool.
I love hiking quarries at friends who would swim in them.
Is that safe?
Guys, I think the elevator works again.
All right, let's go back down.
Long elevator.
Probably not.
Who knows what's leached into that water.
One of my babe games for my one-year win-touriversary.
Prime Stallion.
Thank you so much for a year.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's get all the way back down.
Okay.
Now, why does it work now, huh?
Why didn't it work before?
Hold on, I'm looking for items of this sort.
I guess it's nice.
There's a little save point right here.
Little respawn point.
I can hear them whispering in there.
Scary.
This game's a little freaky.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
Ah!
Holy cow, he scared me.
Oh, having the extra damage on my, uh...
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
On my, uh, thing is so good.
Oh, I think I'm missing every shot.
On my energy is so good, I can hit their shields even.
It's great.
Stop it!
Where are you?
Come here!
And I can hit them with really big things and they die.
Okay.
I think that's all of them.
Alright.
Whoa, look.
There's like caves and stuff.
Why does a direct...
of Stormtrooper aim.
Look, it was that's not one time, and I slapped him.
It doesn't matter.
He died, didn't he?
And guess who's not dead?
The director.
I don't know what I'm looking around at for anymore.
This place is... Whoa!
Look at this map!
Okay.
Let's, um...
What's This way.
Anything?
Bright light.
So bright.
What's bright?
This was a little circle.
Okay.
I think.
I've already lost.
Oh, there.
Okay, never mind.
What's over here?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Tintail, thank you so much for the vibe, get there!
The director is kind and doesn't want to kill unless forced
to.
What's this?
Quarry equipment order.
We need additional diamond blades.
Is this Minecraft?
ASAP.
Continuous rim this time to get the clean cut research once.
This black rock shit is tough.
We're going through blades like we're...
of the damn things.
The dimension for these slabs of black rock they want are
outrageous.
For all the grief they're causing me, these firebreaks
better freaking work a treat.
Go ahead and double the last order.
Tough.
Built for tough.
I'm guessing this is...
Wait, what's that down there?
What is that?
Oh no, it's one of those things!
What?
What are you doing down there?
Oh my god, what are you doing down there?
No!
It was the thing that I had to fight.
I was thought that maybe I only go down there if I fall,
but...
Let's go the other way.
I ignore.
I do not see.
I choose to...
To...
Just don't fall.
Yeah, easy for us.
I mean, I do have that, so that's cool.
There's even stuff up there.
Oh.
So much.
Alright, anything up here?
Nope.
What's the red dot for?
Wait, that's not where I came from.
No, no.
Oh.
Mystery door.
Okay.
Hello, man.
Okay, hello.
How could it see if it has no eyes?
It smells my fear, that's why.
I think...
Oh.
It made a mess.
I tapped it.
I literally tapped it.
I think we have to go that way, after all.
Good to know.
How do I get up there?
Okay.
Hopefully we don't fall.
Hopefully all is...
well I mean what else come I mean there it looks like
there's more down there though it's not a dead end you know
why are the rocks doing this you know why am I asking
questions in a game like this the director has to be
familiar with every inch of this place they're gonna put me
in a sarcophagus and then my body.
I'm gonna... Have you ever thought, like, before you die?
I wish I had done this before I died.
But, like, kind of be like, I said of curse.
I said a curse upon you all.
Anybody who finds my grave will perish.
I kind of wish I had done that.
I wish I had a cool curse upon my grave.
Curse of Minto.
What?
Oh my god.
Oh, ouch.
Well, I'm made it no I didn't who's after me who's after me
who's after me I didn't make it I fell wait what am I
supposed to do now help no please Jesse no Jesse
no Jesse, how are we going to make it out of here?
Go, go, go!
Go!
Okay, we're fine.
No, no, no.
He doesn't see me.
Don't do.
Don't be like that.
Oh my god.
Oh,
this thing is also going up and down.
Jesse!
Look at this place!
If you hit it with launch, it will get stunned.
Hit it with launch.
Oh, really?
Okay, it'll get stunned.
Okay, cool.
That is good to...
Whoa.
Not what I expected.
Wow.
Cool.
I saw some guys down there already.
There's one standing right there.
You think I get him?
Dang.
Ouch.
My bad.
How am I supposed to get back up?
Am I?
I guess we'll find out.
Oh, it's like...
Ooh.
What's over here?
Ooh, it's so shiny.
Oh, it makes noises.
Why does it feel like there's a secret here or something?
you know why does it feel like i can climb all this i can
just i could i could just climb it it does nothing i do have
a sniper you're so right i think i have it let me um i
always just press em pierce yeah yeah yeah yeah wait yeah
yeah pierce and grip
that is the one that i wait
i can't tell the difference between them, I'll be honest.
So where's that?
Is that the guy?
There we go.
I think I got him?
I don't think so.
I don't think I got him, you guys.
I think I messed up.
Is he coming his way?
I don't think he died.
I think he was still there.
Hello?
This place is so cool.
Oh, I don't think he can get up.
Dummy head.
Or...
There he is.
I killed him.
How are you still alive?
Oh, that's right.
Maybe...
Anybody else?
Let's look around.
Ooh, it's so bright.
Oh, it's so bright.
Nice shot, thank you.
Oh, ow, ow!
Oh my god.
Shoot.
Oh, dang it.
I don't think I can pierce him.
Where'd he go?
Where'd you go, you rocket launcher?
Sounds like it's purring.
Can you grab the rockets?
Oh, I don't think I have that unlocked yet.
Unfortunately.
Where'd he go?
He's gonna stress me out.
Shoot!
Come back!
I don't want to go get him.
I'd rather him come to me.
Come on, we can talk this out!
We can talk this out!
We can talk this... Wow!
He's running away from me.
Do you notice this?
Hello?
Come out!
Oh, of course there are.
Hold on, I gotta reload my...
my thing.
My energy.
Yeah!
Aww.
You!
Even more!
Oh.
Hold on.
Oh wait, it's these guys, isn't it?
Wait, what are you?
Actually?
Are they the ones that hate?
What was that?
It scared me.
Actually, wait, is there a thing that's...
Whoa, oh, there is.
Okay, I think we might have to go down for real.
Ah!
Oh my god, I gotta get out of here.
Let's run a little.
Holy cow.
My health.
Oh, I have one HP in a dream.
Was there...
I don't think there was any health around here.
Oh, yeah, there's the thing.
The thing that's healing their HP.
Oh, I knew it.
How am I supposed to...
I think I might die, you guys.
I feel like I might die.
Oh!
Hey!
Okay, it has a limit, understood.
Yeah, I might need to.
Oh, but I can't attack while I have the shield up.
I can't attack while I have the shield up.
Okay, hold on.
This is tough.
Oh,
I think I've almost bought it.
It's so hard to see.
I know there's probably HP pellets down there, but I see
them even.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Took care of that.
Oh my god, there's even more!
Oh, this is tough.
I don't want to get rocket launched.
I'll die for sure!
Oh, it's these guys.
Oh, shoot.
It's the nasties.
Wait.
Let's run.
Ah!
Don't run.
Now run.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
It feels so good.
Yes.
Okay, we're in much better standing.
Barely, but at least better than before.
Where are you?
Oh.
I think I had the wrong gun.
Oh, no, what?
What are you?
Why do you feel normal?
Ah!
F, you are my friend.
Woo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo-lo- Yes,
okay then.
Where'd he go?
Is he down?
Oh no, he's not.
He's tough, he's tough, he's...
Yeah!
Ah!
Another
one!
Ew, it's making a terrible sound.
Heal, heal, heal.
Collect it all.
Oh, we collected it all.
Ah.
We handled it.
Quarry incident report During my weekly safety inspection To
the quarry Who is I have to wonder who's redacting all of
these things You know because I wonder if it's like Somebody
doing Like somebody had to write it without it being
redacted And then they had to re-redact You know I'm so
deeply amused by the age of empires reference I discovered
the entire crew in a state of Redacted The whole team was
redacted Aligned and staring in a uniform direction The city
and the distance Despite my vocal efforts to gain their
attention They remained redacted for more than redacted
minutes Until I had to resort to literally Redacted Probably
killed them right Nope never mind Afterwards they were dazed
and could not provide any rationale for their behavior or
any specific memories of engaging in it my official
recommendation for any crew working in a threshold area is
to either shorten the length of their shifts or to carry out
mandatory psychological evaluations on a weekly basis or
preferably but i thought he killed them he probably kissed
them to wake up yeah i you know when you redact everything
you use your imagination right they remain dazed for more
than 10 minutes until i had to resort to literally kissing
them on the mouth.
Afterwards they were dazed.
That's that's what happens.
Kisses kill.
No wrong movie wrong movie.
Maybe we should order another expedition to the city.
What is the city?
That's new.
That's new vocabulary.
Oh we have a thingy.
Oh we have
Is this a puzzle or is it just light them up, baby?
Minto redacted-o.
What's that sound?
That doesn't sound good.
Wait, why?
Why is it?
What's happening?
Why is there an alarm going off now?
Oh!
I wasn't done exploring, though.
I want to explore a little bit more around this area.
Sorry.
Welcome back.
make I-boos dazed.
No, they were, well, maybe.
They were dazed after getting kissed.
Come on.
You can do it.
Huh.
Yeah.
Oh, there's even more batteries and stuff.
Okay, hold on.
There was something over here I wanted to check out.
That up there was what I wanted to see.
I think that might be the door that was locked, lock it on
this side so I want to make sure to do that.
Oh hello.
Yeah okay okay so now we have a little bit of a way back.
No smoking reminder.
All bureau personnel are reminded to kindly not smoke in the
quarry.
Even though the quarry area is technically an outdoor space
it is still a part of the bureau and therefore no smoking
rule does apply.
Not only is it considerate towards your fellow employees to
remain from inflicting the harm of secondhand smoke it is
also prudent to avoid any risk of gas fires, unforeseen
threshold reactions, and possible creation of altered
receptacles.
Under no circumstances should a cigarette butts be left in
the quarry.
Thank you for your understanding.
This is considered an outdoor area.
I mean, I guess it would be, right?
I mean, are we outdoors?
What is this?
Oh no, I'm a poor BC employee stuck in a supernatural stool
bar.
If only was a cute director who could come wake me up if
only oh how am i gonna get out of this out of this
supernatural funk that i'm in oh no i'm just a poor little
guy um i guess we can go open whatever or hold on
I'm curious up here if there's anything.
I do be exploring.
Can I get up here?
Oh.
Up here?
Come on, Jesse.
Jump with your arms.
I know you have them.
This one's even taller, so...
Ah, here we go, here we go.
Excuse me.
I would like to see what's up here.
I'm very...
Where's all that going to?
Restricted area.
That's not the area we're about to open, is it?
Well, I have to jump through all of this again?
Wait.
I might be making a grave error in order of operations.
It feels like that's gonna open up.
You know?
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything's cool.
I think we're gonna want to open this.
Ooh, ooh!
Little boop!
Whoa!
Never mind that opens up.
Collect the Black Rock Prism.
Oh!
You...
And there it is.
Right where you led me.
Speak...
With Marshal.
Uh-oh.
Shoot.
I need to get this prison to Marshal before it's too late.
HRAs?
Then Dylan.
Where was Marshal?
Marshal was...
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
How many are there?
Oh shoot.
Uh...
Okay.
Please, yes.
Running, running, running, running, running, running,
running.
We're running, we're running.
Too many, yeah.
Too many for real.
Come on.
Let's just have this lawn locked and loaded.
Uh...
I think there's one in here.
Oh, yes, there is.
Oh shoot.
Oh wow!
Okay.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh gosh!
We're running, we're running, we're running.
We're leaving?
We're fast traveling?
Okay, we gotta go to Central Executive.
Okay.
Woohoo!
Nice.
Stinking balls of anterior...
reality oh okay i don't think there was anything else we
needed to do in there anyway so uh it was a tactical you
can't destroy them right at least we don't have the power to
at the moment so tactical retreat or it's the only thing to
do hopes grasping at straws
hi hold on one second
Hi, Jesse.
Uh...
You know, I don't think we need to talk to you.
See you soon.
Yep.
Be careful out there.
I was just kidding.
Okay, anyway, bye.
You can also go back to Explorer when you get redacted.
There's that.
So...
Hello.
I had to take a detour into the quarry, but I found plenty.
Here.
Why didn't we take more than one?
You will start HRA production immediately.
I promised I'd tell you about Dylan once you helped us.
I think the mold conversation gives you a mission.
Does it?
Where we can eat the mold?
Seventeen years.
I've waited.
Your brother is here.
Yes!
He was also known as Crime Candidate 6.
Persona 6.
We brought him here after the ordinary event.
He was groomed to be the future director.
He had talents far beyond any other candidate in the
program.
Of course he did.
We found you together.
We share a bond.
Are you with him now?
So you kidnapped him.
We took him in.
Your parents vanished along with every other adult in
ordinary.
Eventually, his power changed him.
There were casualties.
He wasn't fit to be the director.
Did you know about this?
Uh-oh.
Is this why you didn't bring me here sooner?
Were you keeping me away?
Where is Dylan?
He's kept in the containment sector.
In the Panopticon.
Oh!
My brother.
I thought we were the same.
So we're the director, not him!
Oh my gosh.
I'm going.
Now.
I expected as much.
I need to go check on something.
I know her lashes are so...
I know.
It shouldn't take long, but you must watch the Bureau while
I'm gone.
What, me?
Dylan is dangerous.
He's my brother.
Do not let him out, Director Faden.
How do I make her stop calling me that?
I'm not here for them.
Oh.
Nothing simple here.
These people took my brother, but they've accepted me
without question.
Are they my enemies or my friends?
I need to see Dylan.
I need to know.
I wish you could tell me what you know, explain things.
Just stay with me, okay?
Yeah, the organization is definitely your friend.
I could use a friend right now.
The thing that...
Oh.
Jesse!
my brother is bald oh my god what did you do to him
hey oh we got a we got some more mods and stuff i'll call
that i do want to ask about the mold if it does give us a
mission especially if i can eat it they made him bald jesse
when you were down in research did you run into a dr raya
underhill uh i didn't yeah who is she she was is a colleague
of a researcher studying a kind of extra-dimensional mold
growing research well I don't like the sound of the mold the
mold no one does look I haven't heard from Reya since the
hiss arrived would you mind having a look around for her
next time you're in research of course thanks Jesse now
what's on your mind just mold just the mold actually uh
status of a wish This place is looking good.
Arish is making real progress around here.
What's on your mold?
This place is a fortress.
Mold on the brain?
With him taking care of operations here, I can spend more
time analyzing the Hiss.
Nice.
I've been attempting to isolate and neutralize the Hiss
resonance in blood samples, but no luck so far.
So you can't reverse it?
No.
Not yet.
Perhaps reversing it is too simple.
See, if Hiss resonance can rewrite human genetics, Then
perhaps it's a question of rewriting the Hiss resonance.
But in theory, that could pave the way for custom human
genetic alteration.
I wonder how often the phrase mad scientist is used around
here.
All right.
See you.
I should be going.
Enjoy your data.
Oh, I will.
Oh, she's, like, living for this.
She's so excited.
All right.
Find Dylan is our next objective.
That's exciting.
Look, there's so many people in here now.
It's like we're kind of building a little base of opera.
What was this?
This is Lynn Salvador, head of Bureau of Security.
I'm making a formal security order due to the incident in
April.
Case number 21HQ593.
Improper use of the jukebox alternate item led to two
fatalities.
Some kind of mother base.
We believe a pair of agents use the jukebox to travel to the
quarry threshold and engage in inappropriate workplace
behavior.
behavior an expedition team found them decomposing at the
formation's base a week later at least we found out the
jukebox doesn't bring corpses back when the song ends i'm
having the jukebox placed in a secure location in the
executive sector it should never have been accessible to low
clearance staff in the first place what is the new location
security and proximity to a high traffic area we have not we
have not part taken for expedition we haven't done anything
with the jukebox yet see me for any further details do you
want a fancy outfit there's an unmarked luck puzzle near
essential research fast travel actually I was just about to
hey chill out I was just about to change my outfit actually
let's see let's go back to civilian our first outfit we
haven't had this one in a bit and my abilities we have seven
we can unlock hmm wait why is this one oh I have all of this
large launch large enemies when their health is low wait oh
i did get the grenade and rockets back at enemies i forgot
okay i'll remember there's a jukebox quest that's super
buggy so it's the one quest on my file that's incompletable
oh no wait that's so stinky don't care for the marty mcfly
look it's not that i've just been changing my outfit every
every time we play um
let's see use 10 thingies to I only have 7 but we could get
an additional personal mod slot once we use 10 um I'm gonna
let's see health is 3
um Things are getting tougher, so I feel like I can add an
additional 50% to launch damage would be good.
I think I'll do more health rather than more energy.
And then I could...
I could just save up for more.
For more launch.
Uh...
So...
yeah okay hair loss um hair loss all right hold on let's see
what we've got going on for mission missions here we go fine
using the penopticon the tape where is it we can do all
these maybe before we hold growth locate dr underhill below
central research where is that I wish I could see
Thanks Have you seen us?
Are these devs?
Found.
Please help.
This is so cute.
These are so cute.
The guard by the table has a quest.
Guard by the table.
table this guy I don't think he does not talking to me
unless there's someone else I'm missing you no you you no
you no mm-hmm you no mm-hmm you no mm-hmm
I am here Okay Central research Let's just see what the
Where the heck
is central research Let's just go to the research sector
then I guess Figuring it out from there maybe Confusing
Confusing Place with all the plants Okay Hmm Hmm Oh, I guess
I could have fast traveled, huh?
It's fine.
Uh.
Yes, this is where we are.
Okay.
But even then, it doesn't show up.
I guess below central research.
Okay, I see it.
Okay.
Oh, do we have to go into the maze?
Oh, well, there has been some stuff we haven't checked out,
so...
gonna get um we will probably get uh unless she's like in
here i can't remember what she said to be honest um we'll
probably get ambushed let's just do our best everybody oh
there they go
wow oh oops don't move Quit moving!
Yeah, yeah!
That was sick.
Oh!
More?
Big guy.
I think we're okay.
Property damage.
It's not my fault.
Right?
I'm looking to see if there's anything to grab.
There was anyway this place, there was a lab thing down here
that I wanted to check out anyway.
So I'm happy to be down here.
Well, not happy, per se, but you know.
Down.
It was right down here.
Oh, I thought it was a chest.
oh oh these guys were here before i remember
sadly so sorry oh my god okay um i went in that shelter it
was in here i remember people like baited me to go in here
before but i actually was curious but at the point at the
time i just I needed a save point and not a room.
Intrusive pattern.
Can I sit?
It's so quiet in here.
It's so crazy because, like, you know, we hear all the
voices talking all the time, usually.
What's this?
Oh, wow!
That looks like the silence of the lambs almost.
Song questionnaire.
Auditory experience.
Poets of the Fall.
disquiet.
That's the room I watch all your streams in.
I bet.
Answer questions within two minutes of listening.
Did the song elicit any particular memories?
If so, elaborate.
Did you at any point feel a strong emotion?
If so, what emotion?
Did a clear image of a weapon appear at your mind during the
song?
If so, elaborate.
Provide a detailed description of your current surroundings
as you see them.
Have you ever heard the murmur of voices when no one is
present?
If so, what did they say?
Do you hear them now?
Please choose one from each of the following pairs.
One or two, A or B, day or night, apple or orange, burnout,
or fade away.
It's a good song.
Okay.
Is this the one that's going to be a, what's the word?
Are these the lyrics?
Is this the one that's like copyright, technically?
It's one of the copyrights.
Okay, gotcha.
Oh, I'm going to answer the questions now.
I'm imagining.
Oh, nice.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, look, I'm spinning.
Oh.
They're a real band.
I see.
Yeah, yeah.
Sorry, I talked a lot during song so that you know i don't
get so you know you know so i don't get like so uh copyright
as a usual or rather i don't mind if i get a strike or not a
strike but something on the stream but i don't want to
strike on my channel so i cool would you guys like to answer
the question there now dancing like flames mesmerizing my
darkness quiet playing such and eerie harmonies i think i'm
immune i think i'm immune yeah god i've had enough
commentary to make it transformative exactly i just go ooh
ooh over and over again easy she must be in here
What if I touch it?
Wait, I'm not getting hurt.
Is she down there?
Uh-oh.
Mold.
Oh.
Nice.
Mold.
Eat the mold.
I think we gotta go down.
But if I go down...
Look at that!
Okay.
it if I go down can I even make it you know oh come on Jesse
Jesse
nice oh astro blip okay let's try going down them who's
watching me on these cams oh I'm nervous oh oh Good job.
Uh...
All right.
Wah!
Ah!
Oopsie.
Aw, man.
I'm sure Emily's watching you closely.
I slipped!
Jazz, it's a tea waiting for me to clean the clog, huh?
Wait, am I gonna have to do all of this again?
Heck.
Ugh.
Oh my god.
I already killed all you guys!
Leave me alone.
Wait?
Unless?
Ah!
Oh my god, it's one of these.
Whoa, this is...
Attack, I dare you.
God,
it's still alive?
I think?
Actually, I can't tell.
Oh, yes, it's still alive.
Come on.
Leave me alone.
Oh, holy cow.
I think more will appear though, no?
Oh, maybe not.
Maybe because we did handle them before, even though I died.
Okay, that's not so bad then.
I'll take one round.
You can hit those.
You can?
I didn't realize you could hit them all.
They were invisible.
Good to know.
Okay.
It was over there, wasn't it?
Unless more people appear down here.
Please do not.
Yeah, okay, good.
All right, all right, all right.
That's not, yeah, that's not openable.
All right.
We got this, guys.
Easy peasy.
Okay?
I wish I was full health, but you know.
Can't always be.
Nice.
My knees.
You're telling me.
Alright.
Sure is moldy.
down here.
Urm.
Wow.
Whoa.
Oh, I thought it was crawling up the wall.
Oh, my God.
We're in it.
Why is...
Okay, wait, wait.
Why are we in a bathroom, though?
Why is there an elevator in a bathroom?
You're in some nasty, nasty stuff.
I bet this is really good to breathe.
I'm feeling good.
Oh, building shift.
Must be right.
Even my photo.
It's not immune.
Oh, I thought that might be a thing.
I guess we can just go in, though.
Are you friend?
Oh.
Why are you guys doing down here?
Wait a second.
In here?
I'm the director, excuse you.
Underhill checking in.
Hello, Raya.
How's it going down there?
Enjoying the mold so far?
Settling back into life at the old FBC?
Your coffee with Emily went.
She's a star on the rise.
Incredibly bright, extremely intuitive, but I want to hear
what you thought of her.
I think you two could be very good on a project together.
Could learn a lot from each other.
Let's get together and chat about it soon.
Anyway, Vicky, what do you chintel and nothing like, Vicky?
You think she's British, and so she sounds like Vicky.
Anyway, sorry for the interruption.
I'm sure you can't think of anything besides the mold.
right now literally me you always were a women of mold sorry
focus i've always admired that about you talk soon casper oh
it's dr darling i didn't realize his first name was casper
he would send such like a light-hearted little email right
mold threshold woman of mold so you want to know how my mold
research is getting on casper here it is microscopic
organism similar in appearance to redacted constrict the
architecture of the construct the architecture of the mold I
do not understand if these redacted are the original
disseminators of the mold or are bitten by some fungal
infection the mold is the most prolific and durable organism
I've ever seen I theorize there is a mold source located
somewhere on our side of the threshold rooted here to
accelerate growth in our dimension I refer to this yet
unknown source as mold one.
Yeah, any mold lovers in chat.
The mold produces an enticing aroma to encourage human
consumption of itself.
It propagates.
What if everybody that ate the mold is the ones turning into
the hiss?
Everybody took a little nibble of the mold.
It propagates in the chest cavity and quickly subsumes the
entire body's seizing control of motor functions.
This behavior was not observed when I first arrived.
Which means the mold has adapted to our presence.
Targeting our biological imperatives is a way to spread.
It is a truly ingenious little thing.
A full report will be ready soon.
Keep your slacks on.
Hello.
Why is she smirking at me like that?
Yes?
Hello?
All hail the mold.
Oh.
Sorry, Dr. Darling's recently penned essay titled Redacted
contains some glaring omissions that I feel I must shine a
light on.
Firstly, the entire premise of the essay is that the quarry
threshold is beneficial to the Bureau, while the mold is,
quote, quote, actively hostile to use his words.
We cannot determine the worth of these dimensions in their
life forms using bureaucratic definitions.
Secondly, the mold is much more beneficial than some rock.
If the redacted creating the mold were reconfigured in their
purpose, the structures they could build would rival the
greatest skyscrapers.
Wait, we're going to build cities of mold.
The mold's resistance to various strains of disease we've
attempted to introduce could be derived into redacted.
Yes, admittedly, this application...
There could be nothing wrong with that.
Absolutely nothing wrong.
This application is more difficult than picking up a rock
and gluing it to a wall.
when the Bureau lost its eagerness for a challenge.
City of mold.
Are you smelly just for me?
Hold on, we'll come back to her real quick.
I hate guard duty down here.
This place is fucking weird.
This is nothing.
The clocks?
No, that's weird.
What's weird about a bunch of clocks?
Shut up.
I think that's the new director.
Hi.
Desk of mold.
Dodge efficiency.
Yeah, why stop at skyscrapers?
Beds?
Chairs?
Everything.
Squishy, squishy, delicious mold.
We're doing we're bleaching the mold.
Oh, wait.
My bed.
Mold wife.
Wife's out of mold.
Wifu molds.
X-rays of mold.
Lab coats must be worn in this area.
Don't let mold hitch a ride.
Wow, look at it though.
What's growling back here?
Say.
Okay, let's hear what she has to say first.
I think the mold is like speaking.
Hello.
Do you normally barge into people's private workspaces?
She clearly doesn't know who she's talking to.
Shouldn't you be in a safe room?
Why?
Because of those hiss things the Rangers have.
keep going on about.
Haven't you people sorted that out yet?
The situation down here could spell doom for the bureau.
You mean this mold?
Correct.
Yeah, mold is actually a big problem though, no?
Perhaps you could help me.
Oh.
I require samples of various mold strains and the mold has
made the environment far too dangerous for me to fetch them.
So you're letting me go in?
Really?
Mold samples?
I thought this could spell doom.
It could.
And it will whoever you are the mold is spreading we need to
find the source before it spreads too far any samples will
do that no oh samples of five unique strains when blended
properly will allow you to travel deeper into the pit where
i've pinpointed the approximate location of the source of
the mold oh awesome okay so what do these samples look like
similar to the one on my table there I need was that one
that I saw in there find them throughout the threshold I'll
take a look my name's Jesse by the way I'm sure it is okay
collect five bold sample oh my gosh grows in your
televisions grows near toilets grows near fresh corpses
grows near staircases grows near the pit awesome I need to
get going try not to transport any spores outside the
infected areas we'll we'll attempt oh my gosh i have to
wonder is this like a side quest or will this eventually
lead into like the plot of the game you know smell so sweet
down here oh sniff something really hungry i wonder how this
mold tastes is this a sample or no is this a sample of mold
oh what are you
wait are there zombies jesse wants to eat the mold yes jesse
are those people oh no now we have mold infected people
ah martin thank you i'm sending my support early as i'm
celebrating my birthday later this week yeah wait for the
main birthday circuit hope you enjoy having an amazing
stream living well Happy birthday!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh!
Ouch!
Ew.
It's people.
Oh my gosh, look at all of them!
Ew!
Are they spitting at me?
Is that what they've been doing?
What if they like those?
What if they like this?
They want more of it.
Ouch!
I was right.
It's... It do be spitting at me?
Oh my gosh.
Whoa!
I made it into a pit.
I'm dying again.
once again dying from what from something oh my gosh oh they
regrow that's sick okay let's get out of here mold snipers
yeah disgusting oh i wouldn't say it's safe but i definitely
should probably leave so it's since i'm dying everybody be
careful of the mold almost got me
Oh, come on.
Am I dying to mold?
I can't leave, right?
Wait.
No.
I can't leave.
Oh, my God.
I'm stuck in here.
So, wait.
I did ask the question.
Wait.
It grows near toilets.
Is this a sample?
That's a hand?
Oh, my gosh, that's the most severe swirly I've ever seen.
Your life is bold, Dal.
There's a thing on the wall.
A sample?
Well, let me grab it.
How is there not a sample in here?
Wait, so this is main game, right?
This is not like an optional...
This is not an optional thing, right?
Gross near TVs.
Wait, it is optional!
Oh my gosh, and we're stuck down here.
I can't leave.
Ah!
It's a big side quest, and I'm stuck.
Gross near televisions.
Where are you?
Wait, I wonder if I can leave if I use this.
Let's see, hold on.
Oh, my bad.
Oh, wait.
Um, hold on.
Ah!
Yes!
Yee-oh!
Okay, never mind.
We're free.
I didn't even know what it would be.
It's not the Walking Dead.
Um, what's that other game?
where they become zombies through mold.
Last of us.
Yeah, last of us.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I'm scratching my eye.
Hold on.
I have an edge.
Okay.
Of course.
Trying to shoot at me.
From behind the...
Oh my god!
Ah!
Hmm.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, of course.
I forgot.
Yeah, now it works.
Now you do the thing.
Maybe I can grab his thing.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
There's got to be more, right?
Oh.
Somebody just...
Ah!
Two for one.
Two for?
Did I get the...
Oh, what are you?
Oh, there's multiple of you!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, okay.
Where did these guys come from?
Wait, I don't think I killed the thing that, like, heals the
little dudes, though.
Oh, well.
Intrusive pattern.
What is this?
Threshold utility.
Thresholds have been great sources of great...
Oh, have been sources of great inspiration and great
challenge.
When a new threshold manifests in the oldest house by
redacted, we never know what new discoveries it will provide
to the Bureau.
But we must always seize these opportunities.
This report will examine the process of distinguishing
recent...
Threshold effects based on their utilitarian possibilities.
The quarry brought black rock.
One of our most invaluable discoveries.
But if the mold has any scientific value, it has been
difficult to find due to the lengths we must go to in
fighting back the particularly prolific plant.
These are very distinct cases and worth comparing as their
study offers vastly different dangers and rewards.
So I'm guessing all the mold samples that I would have to
get are like down there.
So...
Um, wait, I guess I could go tell...
I guess I could go tell Emily that she's fine.
Pump station.
And then I also want to get this other...
Other...
Ritual division is where the other tape is at.
Ritual division.
Where is this go-to?
Is this my office?
No.
Wait, what's this then?
Is this the elevator?
Whoa, what is this?
Oh, we're here!
Oh!
Oh wow, look at everybody hanging out!
Hi everybody!
Oh, this is where we solved the prism code thing.
Ah, okay, okay.
Fun, fun, fun, fun.
Wait, great.
Then I can fast travel here?
Is this a fast... No.
Wait.
I can fast travel uh... I don't remember where everything
was.
I keep seeing all these these doodads and thinking that's a
control point.
Ritual division.
Now where was I going?
We were going!
This is perfect!
Wait!
Take him out!
It's a big guy, it's a big guy.
Wait, where'd you go?
Officer?
Whoa!
Oh my god, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm trying to shoot this thing.
Oh, hello.
Hey!
Who's birthday?
Oh, here it is, but this is where we needed to be.
Okay, hold on, sorry.
I want to see you happy birthday.
Whose birthday?
Let's spend my birthday with me too and Iboos.
Say hi, happy birthday!
Alrighty.
Awesome, awesome!
Happy to have you spending it with us too.
Ritual division is where...
Where would it be?
If I were a tape.
In here?
No, that's an elevator.
Wait.
Unless?
Where is this going?
Oh.
Wait, have a...
Wait.
Where am I going?
The sign that says ritual office.
Someone says press R to change aiming shoulders.
Really?
Thank you.
Have I been to here before?
No, clearly not.
Oh, my bad.
Carla.
Thank you for the file.
It was very helpful.
I've re-archived it with the Black Rock research in case you
need to refer to them again.
Yes, the video shoots are always interesting.
I expect my availability for this to decrease in the future,
however, as my analysis of this newly discovered Black Rock
variant is reaching a critical point.
I hope you will be able to attend them still.
Darling seems to be under a lot of pressure lately, and I'm
sure he would appreciate any support you can provide.
Regarding the analysis you provided, I do not have any
questions.
Thank you for the expeditious...
Is that how you say that?
Delivery.
Regards research specialist Dr. Carla Vaughan.
Federal Bureau of Control.
Wait, so.
Oh!
Look at that!
Thank you.
Expeditious.
Vacuum chamber.
But he's old.
Oh my gosh.
Check Hubert's file.
He was flirting with Carla.
I think I remember that though.
What is this?
Embracing the erratic.
An audio journey.
We found it!
Because he must be one of those sensory tape tapes.
Womp, womp.
Anything in here?
No.
Rituals.
We got the tape.
We did it.
Hubert was the one that was flirting with her like in the
cafeteria pretty sure I got her obsessive compulsive
disorder hoarding anxiety disorders while certain
manifestations of these conditions are simply the result of
mental illness sometimes the individuals are simply
performing redacted called rituals the redacted of rituals
can vary numerology dream logic for forfeiture forfeit
forfeit verbal formulae and causal tethering are just some
of the procedures involved.
The ritual.
The ritual, not the goats.
You guys, one time I had a dream that was like these goats.
These goats were like, minto.
You must perform the ritual.
And I was doing everything but, and all the goats were so
bad.
They were like, minto, please perform the ritual.
Some rituals are consistent, such as pulling the light
switch cord through times to enter the motel but some are
erratic while most people engage in minor rituals every day
the vast majority do not understand the importance behind
their actions avoiding disaster amassing luck or simply
locating lost keys are all the results of daily rituals coat
backseating is spread by code now it's different that's the
tron ride at Disney
Avoiding disaster, amassing luck, or simply locating lost
keys are all the results of daily rituals.
Individuals who recognize a deeper meaning behind these
compulsive actions are inherently aware of the paranormal
world and, when located, should be considered for employment
at the Bureau.
Refer to file for full report.
I'm making a mess out of all this.
Whose room is this, anyway?
Well, very cool.
Thanks for the tape.
the imagery experience.
Research.
Research, research.
I thought when
I cleansed a point, it would like make it so that guys
couldn't come back, but I guess not.
Okay.
sensory lab which would be there astral exhibition i
guess we are going back back to i feel like the mines were
so fast no ah okay i vaguely
Right near parapsychology.
This was the bad room, Lomel.
Or I guess he's not in here anymore, huh?
Okay, wait.
Parapsychology.
Maybe I should have gone.
Oh, let's go!
Let's travel to parapsychology instead, right?
Because then we can go through that big room.
Okay, okay.
I think I remember.
Let's travel to parapsychology, right?
Okay.
okay and then it was uh down through over here i remember i
remember we're gonna get ambushed again though most likely
let me know if the audio is sorry i keep i keep mentioning
it and then i keep forgetting to look at chat i know it
might be a little loud during whoa red screen I mean, why?
Riki.
Sounds fine?
Okay, cool.
Thank you.
And it was over in here, right?
Extra sensory.
Okay, thanks, guys.
Okay, here we go!
Embracing the erratic and cardio journey.
What is this for?
Welcome to my guided imagery experience.
Lesson 2.
Exercise 2.
Embracing the erratic.
My name is Dr. Yoshimi Tokui.
Trust my words.
I'm here for you.
Okay.
Now,
close your eyes, open your mind, and find yourself on a
deserted beach.
We're back with the sea goals again.
The waves are crashing against the rocks, and the goals are
circling overhead, drawing ever closer.
Are you scared of birds?
No.
If so, please try not to be.
Oh!
I am thirsty, actually.
A vendor machine.
You must be thirsty.
Let us go quench your thirst.
Agui.
I'm quenching my thirst, everybody.
They have your favorite soda.
You know the one.
Press the button.
Self-service vending machine for all your needs.
The vending machine company.
Oh yeah.
It ran away?
The machine has run off with your favorite soda.
Chase it.
Jido Hambaiki.
Vending machine.
That is your Nihongo of the day.
Jido Hambaiki.
What?
The soda you kill a man for.
This is your favorite soda in the whole world.
It is.
Oh.
The soda you kill a man for.
Soda!
Yay!
The soda tumbles out.
Victory.
But it was supposed to be my favorite in the whole world.
Go on.
You might like it.
It was supposed to be my favorite in the whole world that I
would kill a man for.
How delicious.
This is your new favorite soda.
When you try new things, you sometimes discover the best of
life has to offer.
That's a soda lesson for you.
Come on in.
Honestly, that's like a good lesson though, right?
Because I'm the type of ghost that like, if I have my
favorite thing in my afterlife, like I I typically like
stick to only like I'll go to the restaurant and order the
same thing every time you know what I mean but I guess it's
kind of like if you I actually the other day I tried a new
restaurant and I tried something that seemed really
delicious and it was kind of mid and it's because I mean at
least I'm glad that I tried it but but what if I try
something new and I don't like it And then I feel like I
wasted my time and my money when I know that there's
something else that I like better.
So it's kind of, it feels, I don't know.
Obviously, you can't discover something new that you might
like.
It's a dead person.
This would normally be quite an upsetting thing to find,
yes?
Do not worry.
You are safe.
Why don't you try touching the dead person?
It could be interesting.
Yeah, something interesting could happen, right?
Oh, why am I touching him there?
Oh, where did the corpse appear?
Dozen of more corpse appeared.
Where did they come from?
Oh, the stench, the horror.
This beach will never be the same.
Why did I touch the body?
Finding a new thing you hate happens once, finding new thing
you love lasts forever.
Maybe.
You made a grave mistake.
Fix your mistake by hiding it.
Bury these bodies.
I'm burying them.
Rest in peace.
Hold F to pay respects.
Hold F to pay respects, everybody.
That was scary, wasn't it?
And yet, you learned another lesson.
You're scared of some things for a reason.
Listen to your instincts.
Accept that the world is random and cold.
Fear is useful.
Lots of good lessons today.
Some things are good, some are bad.
Don't you feel more prepared for uncaring cruelty of life?
Maybe.
do.
This concludes my guided imagery therapy.
You are now approved by Dr. Yoshimi Tokui to explore this
rotating rock we call Earth.
Good luck, Star Wanderer.
Stay actualized and see you next time.
Hide the bodies, hide the bodies.
Kojima telling you to clear your mind of the rot, but he
created the MGS brain rot.
The man does it again!
I'm Jesse fucking Faden.
Oi!
You're the best, Dr. Yoshimi.
What did I get from that?
I missed all the little things on the side.
Thanks, Dr. Yoshimi!
I'm Jesse freaking Faden.
Faden.
I knew it.
Oh, I thought something came- How do
I kill this thing?
Where'd it go?
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
They're getting closer!
Yeah!
Take him out.
I think I got him, actually.
Woo!
Woo, foo, foo, foo, foo, foo.
Yeah!
Why did it make
you research?
Oh my god!
What did you do?
look at the detail on this thing this is actually so cool
like they didn't they could have just had it explode into
like you know a big concrete pile but how neat right you
should have gotten a good mod oh yeah hi dog don't know so
you can go back and order something you like if you wind up
accidentally getting something you don't like at the
restaurant oh sorry go thank you it's okay say it was just
like you know when you like see something on a menu and
everything like hits those beats right it was like garlic it
was uh pesto it was so it sounded so delicious and then i
tried it and like it was just kind of like it didn't have
the same like punch that i thought i would get from the
flavor, you know what I mean?
It was just okay.
Yeah, better on paper.
But I wasn't like, you know, I wasn't like, oh, I can't eat
this.
It's so disgusting and terrible.
Like, it was just whatever.
Oh, wait.
I have to be checking my phone.
Matara went out.
Matara went out, but she's coming back.
She left all her stuff.
Wait, what time is it?
Okay, yeah.
She shouldn't be back here.
Um.
I was like, I'm gonna, she said it was fine for me to
stream.
But she was like, I'm gonna, wait, I can individually pick
up each brain piece.
That's fun.
Oh, she said she wanted to go exploring.
Matara might, yeah, she might interrupt the stream,
depending on how long I'm, uh, depending on how long I'm
streaming for.
Uh, did I get anything for Astral?
Oh!
Spin is a generous magazine.
High rate of fire.
Wait.
This is different than...
Unless...
This isn't an upgrade to what I'm ha- what I'm using, right?
Grip is...
Yeah.
Right?
How do I upgrade you?
Unlock by upgrading.
This is some machine good.
Okay.
okay that's what i thought um how do i upgrade you though
well we got some new personal mods oh energy recovery speed
wait what's this one launch energy cost no we'll do the
recovery speed for sure that's great and then we have health
okay great
only as the game progresses oh dang okay good to know we had
new stuff in the hotline oh oh hello I'm averse to using
objects of power.
I don't want to lean on things I ultimately can't trust.
Yeah.
But the ashtray and the cigarette, smoking there forever,
have their uses.
Can we go to the ashtray maze?
The ashtray maze they conjure is an impossibly changing
labyrinth that no one but the binder and those the binder
invites can ever pass through.
I think you have to do the spin before you can upgrade.
the things darling is it time the danger and the risk
involved call for every measure of security and protection I
could bring to the table the maze hands down is our
strongest lock I gave darling and his chosen crew license to
pass through the maze lately I've started oh wait I think
we've seen this one I didn't click on anything though all I
did was click hotline yeah I think we saw this one yeah yeah
right oh that's weird though why would it hmm yeah that was
weird I didn't click on anything certain resources loot can
be constructed crafted into mods forms we advocate
facilitate this at control points menus this will only be
slash exclusive for the director.
I think I've known this for a while, though.
You're telling me nothing new.
But sure, thank you very much.
Do we want to try?
Can I do the ashtray maze?
That was under ritual division.
Wait, actually, I don't remember.
Was, oh yeah.
Central research?
Yeah.
Yes, yes, ashtray.
No, we can't.
Okay, okay.
We can't.
Well then, um, what other missions we got?
We have cleared the clog, but this is at the pump station.
I imagine I can go to here.
Yes.
The coolant pipes.
maybe i won your cutout city i washi expo me though i had to
ship her home glad to say i got her in the mail and she made
it in perfect condition luna thank you i was curious i was
curious now to find the perfect place for her in my mintel
corner congrats thank you thank you thank you thank you what
level badge did you have i have four so i imagine he can't
we have it's down by the over here you can't really see it
um i imagine let's try going to the power no furnace chamber
oops and running from there furnace chamber hello there we
go yeah coolant pumps entrance okay let's try it
i suggest your bed don't suggest that it's cardboard if you
select the mission you can see where it wants you to go yeah
yeah you just couldn't see it because it's it's hidden
behind my head roland leaf welcome to membership thank you
very much thank you thank you let's see all
right coolant pumps ah yes this is where the furnace yes yes
okay wait is this the right way yeah we go through here here
hold on sorry i'll show you here I'll move out of the way.
A little bit.
I'll move back.
CC.
So I think we go through this hole here and then go around
through the cooling pumps and then that should be it.
Oh.
Yes.
Yes, I believe.
I see you in new dragon's dog by trial or I am for some
reason.
That's me.
Pretty funny.
Are there guys here again?
There were before.
Oh, what's up here?
That's mold, though.
Nutritious.
Well, I don't know about nutritious, but they did say it was
delicious.
Boy, I'm off the map.
Where am I?
Where the heck am I?
Well, we've definitely been to here.
Okay, yeah, now we're here.
Alright.
Then, from here...
Okay, we're down here.
If we go...
Okay.
Maybe up over here.
Okay, and down this way.
Yes!
Oh, yes, yes, yes!
Have we been in here before?
Wait, wait, maybe?
Hello again, Mr. Clog.
Hello, Mr. Clog.
Ew!
Wait, can I shoot it from here?
Oh, I don't know if I missed or not.
Okay, I don't think so.
That's fine, that's fine.
What's in there?
Water cooler procedures.
Okay.
Item was discovered within the bureau itself.
Gross.
Item is able- wait, was this door here ever before?
I don't know, whatever.
The item is able to adopt physical form of items in its
immediate vicinity.
Area?
Okay.
I need...
I need two.
Now how- okay, okay, here we go.
I don't need no gamer paint I know where to go we're fine I
don't need no gamer paint oh but it won't let me open this
oh wait what is this to oh
wait here's why I totally missed it my bad
You?
Come on.
Get out.
There we go.
Okay, but we need both.
So...
Take...
Oh no, you're so...
Uh...
I thought I was inside.
Okay, there we go.
Um...
No!
You're so...
Oh no, wait.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Wait.
How did I just do that?
Oh, wait.
Where did it go?
Ah!
No way.
What?
How did it get...
It's okay.
I don't think we're soft locked.
Or anything.
We just have to redo it.
We'll just do it from here instead, right?
There we go.
And I'll do it from up here.
I think...
Oopsie.
I think that's going to open and I want to be prepared.
Activate the draining pump!
Wait, is that it?
Oh, oh, just kidding.
Activate it.
How?
Oh.
Uh.
I didn't mean to do that.
My bad.
Ah, yeah.
Here we go.
Go to the lower level and push back the claw.
I had the wrong lever.
My bad.
La la la.
I'm the janitor's assistant.
Everybody has to do some sort of janitorial job at some
point in their afterlife, you know?
Because it's important.
to get these kinds of skills.
Hello?
Am I dumb?
Oh.
Oh, whoops.
That was the light.
There we go.
Goodbye, Mr. Crog.
I sincerely hope we never meet again.
Yay!
Oh, that one was so easy.
Rookie janitor mistake.
Ooh.
Thank you for all the supplies.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, wrong thing.
What's, what's, what is there?
We have energy recovery speed at health, but what is this
one?
Launch.
Energy cost minus 16.
Well, the other one was what?
Minus 14.
My siblings didn't know how to wash dishes by hand because
of that.
No way.
Have you ever seen that?
What was it?
It was like a clip.
It was like some.
So I don't.
I saw like a clip of what are the Kardashians?
She was like trying to cut an apple or something and was
doing it like her arms were crossed and everything.
It was just like.
But you know.
Some people really just don't learn.
Like you think some things are common sense.
But some people just.
Don't learn, you know?
Some people just don't learn.
We'll keep the energy recovery speed for now.
Because that seems a little bit better.
Alright, and we can get some...
I think we'll probably will be ambushed coming out now.
Since we weren't here itself, you know.
So probably when we leave here, we'll be ambushed.
Did you see the video of the classroom learning how to use a
can opener?
No, I did not.
Though I also don't like using can openers.
Well, the automatic ones I don't mind.
But, like, the hand ones, I struggle with, actually, though.
What was that?
Uh, so find Dylan.
Containment, Penopticon.
Where was that?
I'm not a tiny weak, girl.
Shit.
I told you.
I told you all.
I think we're fine.
We're not fine?
We're fine?
We're fine.
We're not fine?
Yeah, you just...
babies don't pop out cutting apples to be fair i don't think
so i've never heard of one but i've never heard of a lot of
things so
i couldn't be certain
all righty let's head to oh we have wait um what are we
gonna i think what i did health Let's do energy.
Hello.
All right.
Let's do...
I don't have enough points.
That's okay.
Let's travel back to executive, central executive.
Fruit ninja babies!
Yeah.
Kangaroo babies do, actually.
They come out kicking, literally, and climbing.
They climb the mama.
Kangaroo babies are born and then they have to climb.
Be glad you weren't born as a kangaroo.
Or maybe you're jealous.
I don't know.
Maybe you love climbing.
One second.
I'm waiting to see if Mataro messages me.
Oh wait, she said...
Oh.
She's complaining about the weather?
Okay!
My brother!
Where is my brother?
Where is a Panopticon?
Fast travel to...
No really, how do I get there?
Where is my brother?
Oh, wait, no, where is my brother?
It's a new section, so you need to use the elevator.
Got it.
You guys followed you in, right?
There was one elevator.
I can't remember, but then on the side here there was a door
that was like level four.
And now I can open it and so I want to try.
But I don't know where, I don't remember where it was.
Was it upstairs?
From here?
Wait, literally just upstairs of here?
My brother.
Did you see me take down one of them flying, mother freaker?
Oh, wait!
Yes.
Whoa.
Weapon mod.
Shatter projectile.
I keep pressing the wrong thing.
Projectile spread absolute.
Minus 23%.
I guess I'll try it.
Oh.
They've missed, they missed a couple spots.
Is there anything in, oh, there it is.
Sticky note complaint to who it may concern.
In case you are not aware, something caused a sticky note in
my office to duplicate.
My office is unusable now.
I will be working from home until this is resolved.
You can reach me on my cell or my home phone.
Sincerely, bozo.
Vice Chief of Staff.
Wait, so he's probably immune to the history.
right now.
Lucky guy.
His work from home saved him.
J.
Bozo.
Do as you're told.
Don't eat the mold.
Someone is defying it.
They're saying, yes, eat the mold.
Yes, he...
Wait, maybe he's totally done for them.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he ate the mold.
He ate the mold.
Spinning out of control?
Yes!
Some new people.
Itamau.
It tastes good.
Even Jesse wanted to try.
This is such a funny, like.
Sometimes SCPs are so fun because they're so like...
They're so bizarre.
Thank you guys for telling me about where that room was.
I wanted to find it, so I'm glad now.
My curiosity has been satiated.
But yeah, sometimes SCPs are so like...
Goofy in that regard, you know?
My dad has issues remembering to do things, so he'd write on
sticky notes.
This is literally what his office would look like after a
while.
No way!
You get mold immunity if you do the side quest.
Maybe we will do it...
...next time.
Not to say that I'm stopping at the moment, but...
Wait!
Wait, these...
Did these have sticky notes on them before?
Wait, uh-oh.
I think all the...
I think the sticky notes have spread.
No?
Wait, this is another room that we can go into now, too.
That I couldn't before.
Very nice!
Is this that radio show?
Dodge efficiency.
Oh, it's just noise.
They were there, I think?
Okay.
Oh, this is this one, no?
The jukebox!
It's the jukebox!
What the...
I don't think we know exactly what it does, though.
Okay, I thought I remember seeing it.
But what do you do?
Jukebox?
The found was definitely there.
Okay.
You heard, right?
She's the new director.
Yeah, whatever.
Juice box.
Containment sector?
This is so exciting.
Wait.
Right.
Talk to the guy in lobby for joke box.
Mold immunity is necessary to explore certain areas, but I
don't remember if there's a specific side quest that
requires it.
Hotline cannot.
Oh, oh, sorry.
Oops.
I was too early.
It's okay.
The containment sector, the Panopticon, is home to the
altered items we find and contain.
Oh, I'm so excited.
This is a maximum security prison.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
It's a powder keg big enough to blow this world to dust.
A temple, a place of worship filled with idols of angry
gods.
these and none of them it's something more profound yeah i
see p time for real i'm sorry i'll move my cursor something
worse idols my oh she's in here we found many my oh she's in
here she looks so cute cute mo kaii from the truth they're
all powerful dangerous dangerous they press heavy on she's
dangerous for my heart They've been altered because we can't
stop thinking about them.
We put them on altars because they're used to being
worshipped.
This keeps them calm.
We contain them, but they don't want to be controlled.
We study them to discover what makes them tick.
If this place were ever breached, it would be chaos of
biblical.
proportions nice oh an opticon sorry we're re-watching it
altered items maximum security prison dangerous we're
getting the cliff notes version
whoa trench and guy Whoa.
TV!
Wait.
Oh, okay, just kidding.
Oh.
Nothing's on, though.
Northmore!
That would make sense, right?
I didn't realize that's what he looked like.
Oh, geez.
Yeah!
Oh, dang!
I think it was that guy, actually.
Ah!
You.
You matter to...
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, I should have turned him into my friend!
I'm sorry!
Oh, I should have turned you into my friend!
Hehehe.
I'm missing out on how many friendships
Oh, no, no, no, no Nice, what is a yellow in here?
Wow, there's so many people in here, too.
We got the, uh, the MGS3 filter on in here.
It's okay, I didn't need more friends.
Alright, so this is the bold, right?
like a little pet and everywhere.
Objects and item distinctions.
While altered items and objects of power may seem similar at
first, it's important to note they have very key
distinctions.
Firstly, objects of power grant peri-utilitarian abilities.
Secondly, objects of power translocate anyone who makes
physical contact to the astral plane.
So objects of power basically are the things that give me
all my cool stuff.
This is wildly believed to be due to the its affiliation
with objects of power maybe the boards not every individual
is allowed in the astral plane which indicates the the board
evaluates who are who and who who cannot can or cannot enter
I'm guessing it's the board oops yeah the oops the objects
of power are oops thirdly and this is not always the case
objects of power are much more perinaturally redacted than
altered items stronger maybe well why do I walk in on Paul,
who?
Oops.
Looking at the specific criteria that defines an object of
power, it is no wonder they are notably rarer than altered
items.
In fact, we have redacted altered items for every object of
power contained within the Bureau.
Oh.
He's...
Oh, no, I don't want a Bureau alert.
Don't talk to me.
I'm busy.
Sorry, I don't want your...
I don't want your...
optional thing please oh it's so yellow why who put the
yellow tint on this sunroof please
everybody's freaking possessed remote thought okay so we're
in here now oh we have to go quite far now don't we
Interesting, interesting.
Ow!
Awesome.
Uh, before we go in there, and ultimately have a bad time,
let's check up here.
Anything?
Yes.
Reminder.
This week, any documents that...
that suddenly appear pink, like red, or any shade in between
must be incinerated immediately.
Failure to do so will result in termination and possible
bodily harm.
Oh.
Thank you for your attention.
Boy, pink.
Seize accelerator.
Pink like the cubicles.
You guys are color blind.
into this hellscape.
Oh my gosh.
Oh wait, you can be my friend.
You can be my friend.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa.
We're okay.
I told you I didn't need my friends.
I told you.
I told you all.
Good job not dying.
Thank you.
It was pretty close, though, huh?
Wow.
Alrighty.
Ooh, some of these areas are so cool.
It's no longer red and scary.
Just a little messed up.
The lady's room is unlocked, everybody.
Come on in.
Wow, there's a lot going on.
Wow!
Okay, wait.
Hold on.
Let's...
There's so much to explore.
Logistics.
Security, medical wing, panopticon.
I might have...
Done a little bit of damage in the area.
Oh, okay, even more.
Alright, I'm just checking out the area real quick.
That didn't sound good.
Oh man.
There's the music.
I think they're going to be following me in here,
unfortunately.
All I want to do is...
Hold on, I'm just... Ah!
Ah!
Whoa!
Whoa, buddy, whoa, buddy, whoa, buddy, chill, buddy, chill,
buddy, chill.
Not damage redecorating.
I am the director after all.
I decide what, uh...
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, shoot.
What is this?
Oh, that's the...
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
Bitch!
How did you reload so fast?
Shoot that guy.
Get him?
Get his ass?
1,000 sources.
Sorry, 100,000.
Did he die already?
Friend, you're so weak.
My friends are stupid.
I suck.
All right.
Well, thanks for...
I was trying to explain.
explore and we just made a mess of the place.
Now I feel like I can't explore properly.
Did they all come through from in here?
I can't remember.
I don't know.
I think I saw them from up here, I think.
I think.
She doesn't need friends.
They disappoint her, yeah.
This place is humongous.
Okay.
Humongous among us.
There's so many doors.
They just like to respawn here if you take so much a step
out of the room.
I know, right?
A little bit of a gripe with the game.
Because, like, it's one thing if, like, I kill, if I, like,
take them out, and then they respawn, but, like, to a lesser
degree.
You know what I mean?
I would even take, like, one strong guy or two strong guys
over, like, over a full wave.
you know what i mean so let's see everything is compromised
except richmond atlanta topica salt lake city is that santa
fe it gets a bit tiresome it can yeah it can okay some of
these i think were definitely like here before the
that's so funny some of the sticky notes I'm just looking
for stuff to read right now but it doesn't seem like a whole
whoa dog thank you so much for the pep day captain thank you
thank you thank you I really appreciate it thank you so much
also wait oh the doors That's kind of scary, no?
That's kind of freaky, no?
Wall of honor.
Okay, hold on.
I wanted to...
I wanted to switch for... Oh, that's why.
Shatter projectile joke.
I didn't want to use the shatter.
I wanted to go back to my grip.
Um...
Okay.
In memory of the heroic agents who gave their lives to
forces known and unknown for the protection greater
knowledge of all mankind we honor their sacrifice are these
devs or are they they're this is where the patrons go the
patreon patrons grip plus shatter the shotgun seems a bit
yeah maybe that instead of oops instead of uh the pierce the
pierce is fine the shatter is just you know is this mold
what is that I can't tell actually
beep beep beep beep beep oh there's bad music who's in here
I don't know
oh wait I want to let me in wait there's something to read
okay let's go on the other side I guess maybe
maybe Oh, medical wing.
Ah, Ida.
Why is there purple coming out of there?
Woo, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
My
friend's about to die.
My friend.
Lai-mo!
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Hi, Lai-mo.
so much fun but I haven't met dr. darling oh it's purple in
there oof okay wait I haven't met dr. darling yet I'm a
little sad about that I am having so much fun Imo and I were
talking about control the other day together
anything north tell it to me straight
How much longer do I got?
I want to give Dr. Darling a kiss.
I'm changing my last name to Darling and getting a PhD.
No, I am.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't even notice what I got.
I was checking Matara's messages.
I just want to make sure I catch her if she's in the...
know here or not excuse me these are these are a little
spooky no it is mold oh my gosh
oh there's something in there though isn't there am i crazy
oh yes oh there's a thing i'll have to get clear in six for
that though and this yeah all right We'll come back.
No, yummy snack.
They didn't say they would provide lunch.
Oh.
Are those mold people?
Oh my gosh, we have to fight them anyway.
Get out of your mold person.
Wait.
Why is he just laying there?
Oh, this seems bad.
Wait, this seems bad, bad.
Mold autopsy.
Oh, you said, okay, never mind.
The deceased was a blank-year-old blank with no significant
past medical history.
Old people.
It is the last of us.
The subject was brought in after being discovered in the
active threshold in an early state of decay that is
characteristically fungal-based in its appearance.
During autopsy, the cadavers' plural cavities were revealed
to be entirely filled by the fungus known as the mold to an
extent that medical staff were forced to put on
decontamination suits.
The procedure was also hindered by anomalies such as the
deceased's high body temperature and undulating torso
muscles presumably but not probably caused by trapped gases.
Routine samples as well as tissue samples requested by Dr.
are successfully extracted, however, their rapid
retrogression outside of the host body needs to be noted.
Cause of death, mold ingestion.
They're gonna be coming for me.
Oh, wait.
Ah!
How do they know how to open the doors?
Take one body.
Where are you going?
Stupid.
Stupid?
Stupid head?
Yeah, you're too dumb to open doors.
The dumbest mold person alive.
Or not?
I don't know.
Probably.
Personal mod.
Oh, it's a C's accelerator.
I wonder if this would be a better time to get the mold
resistance.
You know?
Ah!
You guys, they come back!
Oh, geez.
Wait, how am I supposed to get out now?
Wait, there's too much mold!
I'm in trouble!
Ah!
Are they shooting at me?
Oh my gosh, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Get me out of here!
Was that a person?
Old person?
No.
We're just gonna leave.
Get me out of here.
I don't want to come back.
Where am I?
Security.
So medical wing is like completely compromised.
The music hasn't stopped.
They're still stalking me, I think.
This sucks.
I'm getting stalked by mold.
I don't want to eat it anymore!
I lied!
Oh, there's a mold person.
What does the four mean?
Oh, okay.
There was a single mold person following me.
Um, what does the four above them mean?
Federal Bureau of Control Security Center.
Just their level.
Okay, okay.
This is...
Gosh, everything is clearance level six.
Prime candidate program.
Me!
Transit corridor.
ah that okay so the detour we went okay now we're back we're
back around globe procedures no unique procedures required
however contact should be limited it item is handmade set in
dark wood the item itself is lacquered hand painted spins
freely on all axes axes while the con continents and oceans
are those of Earth.
Careful examination has revealed numerous redacted and other
geographic additions that do not exist on our planet.
One of these islands has a city marked on it named Tan
Rilio.
There are no signatures left by its marker.
Physical contact renders subjects dizzy and disoriented with
some reporting a feeling of unfamiliarity with their
surroundings.
This effect seems to grow worse with prolonged contact,
culminating in a sense of listless lest list list this and
depression suicide has been observed in redacted handlers
okay so that guy won't help me out he kind of sucks don't
touch the globe remote slot
So, okay, we gotta go down through security.
Oh, we're going up, up, up, up.
Never mind.
Oh.
Darling.
Minto has been controlling me for one year.
Bro, so thank you.
Oh.
I can't hear you.
The agents found their way up into the building.
It's so quiet.
Once we became aware of it, it was there.
For the rest of the population, it was hiding in plain
sight.
Thanks.
A slippery blind spot, seemingly discouraging observation.
Sitting in the front row of a movie theater?
It's a place of power.
An ongoing AWE of its own.
Seemingly adhering to its physical outer constraints, and
yet constantly breaking the known boundaries of reality.
It's unstable.
Shifting.
Note.
more details on control points and the research and process
to stabilize and secure the core sectors refer to a separate
presentation oh after extensive research investigation the
Bureau made the building its headquarters on November 13th
1968 the Federal Bureau of Control was never out of the open
this was always an obfuscated classified top secret
operation So imagine our surprise when the building's
observation-resistant aspects began in some unquantifiable
way to affect the bureau as a whole.
Tiny head, yowie hands.
Thank you.
Ooh, shield boost.
Oh, but I don't use shield often.
I guess let's go down, huh?
Wait, I'm gonna...
Okay, hold on.
Check this.
down, but only on this side I can collect the health.
I feel like if I get ambushed, I'd rather have full health
for it.
Right.
Or close to full health.
Closer?
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, there's a shelter here, too.
That don't look good.
Oh, no!
Oh!
Okay, it's fine.
Uh...
Hanopticon cells, multiple.
Breached!
Security response on route.
Oh no.
A-O.
That doesn't sound so good.
Nobody made it to the shelters.
It's so bad.
Spin rate of fire boost.
Grip.
Oh, weapon, enemy...
What do I have right now?
Damage.
Just damage.
Damage against enemy armor.
72%.
That's not bad.
But we'll stick with what we have at the moment.
Wait, let me in.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
What?
It's fine!
Oh, okay.
Everything's okay.
We're styling.
Well.
And then here.
Sorry, I thought it was a file.
Never mind.
Pierced and fire boost?
No.
Oh.
I do have some personal mods, though.
Launch efficiency?
I think I...
Oh, shield strength.
Let's deconstruct these guys.
Energy recovery speed.
Well, even deconstruct this guy.
Can I go in here?
Whoa!
Oh!
Wait, what do I do here first?
What does this do?
Altered items.
breached p6 is what the bureau calls dylan p6 has been
breached has the his found him oh are you there with him can
you protect him oh oh that's me oh wait there's something
here energy boost oh that's like not much i think
deconstruct All right, let's do it, baby.
A one.
Ah!
Is that my brother or two?
Three!
Whoa, what's he staring at?
This is locked.
Of course.
Oh, yeah.
Whoa.
I could finally see the TV.
I'm nervous about what's going on in there.
I didn't think the motel was dangerous.
You know?
What did that do?
Aha, I flipped the whole room back.
Nice.
Is that ladder always here?
Are we doing some construction?
A little bit of maintenance?
Goodbye!
A one.
Are we gonna see our brother again?
Two?
Three?
Let's
see!
Cool.
Let's go.
It's been a long time since Dylan and I knew each other.
I've wondered about him.
What kind of man he'd grow up to be.
Or things as hard for him as they were for me.
Maybe in here.
They were even harder.
Well, it seems like he got locked up pretty early on,
though.
Or maybe they tried to do the tests on him.
A bit later, goes.
Mark.
He's in his own...
Like, his cell is literally marked on the thing.
That's crazy.
Oh.
Ah, T?
Speak with the Panopticon supervisor.
Langston.
Oh.
Hello?
Don't stare at me and sing.
That's creepy.
So things are under control here.
Watch your steps.
Cell breach is popping up all over the place.
This guy.
Hello.
Oh, hello.
Hi.
Is there something I can help you with?
I'm Jesse, the new director.
I need to get inside.
New director?
Yep.
Right.
Well, okay.
Hello.
I'm Frederick Langston, the Panopticon supervisor.
best time for a tour i don't care this everywhere numerous
cell breaches and system failures across the board but
you're the director so here we go founded by zachariah
trench the pen opticon is our state give me the spiel for
all altered i don't have time for this never mind don't give
me the spiel i was told dylan faden was kept here can you
help me find him p6 faden uh sure darling wanted him
somewhere secure and isolated away from people He's in the
maximum security cells, upper level.
All right.
But there's currently a pressing matter, ma'am.
We've got an object of power loose in there.
It's wrecking the place.
The Benikoff TV.
It's a real doozy.
Did I read that one?
I don't think so.
Salvador took a team in to handle it, but no one's heard
from them for hours.
Yikes.
This is a Category 5 OOP we're talking about.
And if we don't contain it soon, it will tear the pen off to
con apart.
Oh, no.
We don't want all those altered items getting loose, ma'am.
No, trust me.
Dylan's in there.
open the door Langston I'll handle it if you say so I
usually tell first timers not to touch anything so just do
that here I'll get the door for you and please ma'am call me
Fred thanks Langston no dang subdue the Benikoff TV object
of power fourth floor only if you can reboot the cell door
protocols without manually accessing them sir oh
lengthen's kind of funny sir i am not at all is this about
the tv oh no it's about a thermos oh dear diner oh my god
it's the oh dear diner what the blue coffee with a white
plastic cap and a logo of the Odeer Diner located in Bright
Falls, Washington.
The cap doubles as a mug.
The item responds to formula I.16, yet no discernible
altered item or effect has been discovered other than
keeping liquids warm for surprisingly long periods of time.
It's just an effective thermos.
It's also worth noting that the coffee from the thermos is
always refreshing and strong, no matter its quality before
being poured into the thermos.
the item what if you can pour like water in there and it
turns caught into coffee it's like uh yeah alan wake
reference it's like it's like coffee jesus maybe alan wake
is just that the thermos was discovered on the shore of
cauldron lake outside of the town bright falls both are
known sites of a recurring a w e see bright falls a w e case
According to witness team, it's Alan Wake.
See Prime candidate program entry for further information.
Who went missing shortly before the discovery of the thermos
has been seen redacted collecting similar thermoses for a
redacted purpose.
Yeah, I do be collecting those thermoses.
So many cell breaches.
The Panopticon.
Dylan's close.
power might wreck this place before i find him subdued we
like i said we don't have anything on the tv right case
files uh
didn't i don't think i don't see anything about a tv
i feel like the redacted was the word unknown it's just
collecting them for no for an unknown reason
Oh, okay, cool.
Langston might have something to say about it.
Let's see.
Hi!
Is the TV back in its box yet?
No.
No rush or anything.
It's just, you know, an ongoing concern.
Um.
Trench.
Did you work closely with Trench?
Oh, he spent most of his time with Darling and all them.
circle the inner circle certainly had his favorites not the
click oh my god is the fbc click did you know the bureau has
a no smoking policy it does oh just not for trench aha still
he is the one who put aside funding for the panopticon not
that i care the man did have vision hmm working at the
bureau do you like working at the fbc sure i mean yeah the
drama is a bit much but i get better benefits here than i
would over at the postal service i checked better i checked
that's not to say i don't like my job man i've been here
over 15 years no one knows the panopticon collection better
than me wow i'm uh close to them in a way interesting i
can't tell if that's creepy or normal here interesting
interesting what is your background how did you get this job
yeah started as a junior agent because my uncle knew a guy
oh nipple baby An accident left the containment sector
severely understaffed.
Ah.
At which point I got bumped up to management.
Put in a steady eight hours a day for another ten years and
voila, supervisor.
I just picked up a gun.
Or a gun picked me.
I like him.
He's funny.
What's the difference between objects of power and
alternatives?
Think of them like storms.
Objects of power are like tropical cyclones or hurricanes
for the uneducated.
They're big, rare, and scary.
Of course, directors can just bind the OOP and become the
eye of the storm.
Altered items are more like weird thunderstorms.
Some may rain frogs, some may rain corn.
But they all rain something.
Oh, my gosh, a corn storm would be amazing.
And how's the his factor into all that?
It's changing them, making them aggressive.
Now they're all raining, I don't know, knives.
Oh, knife rain.
Knife rain.
Nice metaphor.
What was the crap attack?
Rain of corn.
A frog cornstorm could be something.
It would be something.
But I just want the corn.
I don't need the frogs.
Rituals.
How do you keep the altered items under control?
It depends on the item.
Each one has different needs.
Ritualistic touches go a long way.
Singing to the...
Did he say...
Slipping the lights three times, that sort of thing.
It's not superstition if it works.
I'll see you later, Langston.
Hey, listen to... I'll be here.
Hey, listen to it.
I hear them
talking in there.
It's funny.
I'm just looking around.
Wow, the size of this place is crazy.
so cool very very cool very very cool what guys I think I
will end this here today we will continue what do I have
more on Sunday this is a good place to oh wait oh my god
Matara Matara was like like she's she sent me a picture and
she was like i needed to go again before i left and took a
picture of a of a restaurant we had gone to together i guess
she really liked it that's so funny is matto okay yeah she's
totally she actually she was doing you know she was she was
uh she had been having a rough time but she said that the
trip with me and, you know, coming to visit me really
brought her back to feeling more normal.
So, I'm glad for that.
Yeah.
So, we were just chilling and having a good time.
Yeah, so, yeah, it's good.
She, you know, she still probably needs a little bit more
time, but she I think will hopefully she just keeps telling
me she's like all I want to do is stream again you know so
yeah she just wants to keep she wants to get back to
streaming in Japanese imagine yourself at a beach you stare
at the sea and suddenly realize the ultimate secret to inner
peace it is redacted so life changing henceforth you
henceforth you shall always redacted wow congrats oh yes
of the peak.
Yeah, she misses the Momos.
But I think she's, you know, I think she said that she's
feeling a lot better, but a lot more like herself than she
has been these past couple of months.
So, that's good, that's good, that's good.
I'm glad.
And I had fun, you know, even though she's a menace to me as
well.
But, hmm.
If you missed your Matawa streams, hopefully they come back
sooner rather than later.
the stream glad to hear my thoughts feeling better thank you
you tend to have that effect on people i'm not even doing
anything i'm not even doing anything but i'm very excited to
thank me thank you to um hold on i should respond um
continue this i'm really excited for this area and seeing
our brother how much more do you guys think i have of this
room i love how you two support each other I secretly
poisoned her food.
I'm just kidding.
Unless.
Let's see.
Wait, I put it for Saturday.
I might change it to Sunday.
I might switch crime scene...
Wait, no.
Wait.
Yes?
I might switch crime scene cleaner.
Control.
We'll see.
I thought I put it on Sunday.
Valerius, thank you so much for the podcast!
Thank you, thank you!
You also seem to be doing fine now.
If you ever feel emotionally wavy, remember we are here for
you too.
You guys always make me feel better.
I always, you know, I stream.
Sometimes, I mean, truth be told, sometimes there's like
days, like almost today where I was like, I just don't feel
like streaming.
I feel so like...
I feel so...
You know, just like...
How do I describe...
like i don't know my brain is mush and i feel like i won't
be articulate or interesting or funny or you know able to
entertain but you guys always make me feel better so
ultimately i i push through it because i like streaming i
like hanging out with you guys so you know and i don't i
don't like canceling stream because some people are you know
i i know for sure when am i would my like is just like, oh,
I can't stream today or something.
I'm like, no!
What am I going to watch?
So, yeah, I get it.
I'm glad we could help you get through the stinky days.
Yes, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Just happy Johnny hasn't eaten Mataria.
I wish he would.
Hope you're feeling a little less grumpy, Director Minto.
Have fun with Mata.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, well, I'll get to hang out with her a little bit more
before she heads home.
Yeah!
There's still time.
He still has time.
He still has time to do so.
But thanks guys.
I hope you have been enjoying Control because I really am.
This game is so cool.
And I'm really excited to be going around this area.
And look how cool it is!
The Panopticon!
And we'll see our brother next time.
time maybe and fight a tv apparently that'll be cool my show
is on and my show is also on me thank you guys thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you uh glad i found you
on the tubes yeah thanks for finding me on the tubes what
should I name my new all gray male kitten mr.
gray little gray guy we like hanging out with the attunement
though Allah give Matta a hug for us if you can withstand it
I know she hugged me today and I was like I felt like you
know when you do like hug an animal and they kind of like
squirm and wiggle to get out of the arms like
anyway thank you so much have a good day have a good day
have a good day have a good night have a good time zone and
I'll see you when we are busting some SCPs and some hiss
next time thank you everybody thanks for letting me be sorry
if I was a little grumpy and low energy next time hopefully
not hopefully I get some tonight.